tu préfères qui toi tu préfères Mandela
au soccer
King même tous ceux qui m'a cité
c'est vraiment ils ont vraiment eu des
combats c'était c'est admirable
seulement Sankara c'est quelque chose
qui nous appartient encore plus nous
noirs
de l'Afrique il s'est battu pour
l'Afrique pour l'Afrique qualité et
c'est vrai qu'après ça a dépassé
l'Afrique c'était universelle pour moi
ça a plus de portée encore tu préfères
Booba
il n'y a pas la même morale les riches
se sont eux qui vole le fils les douanes
et qui exploite le peuple il y en a de
la chance d'avoir une personnalité qui a
marqué aussi par sa liberté de ton
impertinence de moins en moins de gens
qui ont les couilles de assumer leur
propos donc c'est bien là d'avoir des
référents comme ça comme Thomas Sankara
qui tient une tête aux grandes
institutions
mondiales financières aux plateformes
politiques aux élites on va dire aux
oligarques et ça s'appelait la jeunesse
[Musique]
le numéro 1 et le numéro de le numéro a
été le président Thomas Sankara le
numéro de Blaise Compaoré
[Musique]
on dit que c'est le contraire qui
s'attirent c'est la dialectique qui dit
ça tu crois que c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé l'un compléter l'autre un
par son expression son charisme son
éloquence et l'autre par plus sa réserve
qui savait écouter mais qui parlait
moins
[Musique]
était miroir qui reflète l'opinion de
son interlocuteur il vous dit ce que
vous voulez entendre
il sait pas ce qu'il pense
et Thomas c'est le contraire je dirais
il est ouvert je dirais que
il s'expose comme c'est pas permis
c'est bon d'avoir un homme à qui on
puisse dire tout presque tout
en lui laissant le soin de deviner ce
que l'on appelle le courage de lui dire
c'est bon ce sera et c'est très rare et
ça et en même temps c'est toujours parce
que ça implique sur l'autre
nous sommes d'efforts
pour jouer un rôle être réceptif
ils ont été pas seulement des
camarades révolutionnaire mais ils ont
été véritablement des frères en fait ils
étaient ils étaient proches à un point
que Blaise comparé comme il avait pu ses
parents le père de Thomas Sankara il
s'était proposé de l'adopter donc au
final ils étaient vraiment comme des
frères presque comme des frères de sang
pas que des frères d'armes
c'était tellement inamitié fusionnelle
que le jour du mariage de Blaise
Compaoré Thomas Sankara et c'est presque
sans titraille c'est presque senti
abandonné en fait tellement ils étaient
proches il avait l'impression de perdre
de perdre son ami
président Thomas Sankara était le témoin
de mariage de Blaise Compaoré
je me rappelle de cette phrase terrible
quand il a pris la parole il a dit à la
dame madame
j'ai perdu dans ce mariage
un ami un frère un camarade donc c'est
tout dit des liens qui unissaient ces
deux personnes
je suis en train de chercher un système
pour voyager clandestin mais ça pourrait
coûter cher
et je voudrais que chacun se rassure et
sache que je veux un peu partout je vais
à l'est à l'ouest
il me manque seulement un concours parce
que la nature
donc on y va
[Musique]
quel moment donné le jeune sera prenait
beaucoup de place prenez beaucoup de
place il faisait la leçon à tout le
monde
c'est très bien que c'était ton match en
direct beaucoup de monde pas seulement
la France il y a la question du
capitaine Sankara le jeune les nouveaux
et bouillant dirigeants qui est venu
mais avec semble-t-il quelques
réticences la France ne comprend pas
l'Afrique et les grands tant que la
comprenne
il a un charisme naturel oui il est beau
gosse il s'exprime bien ses idées sont
claires c'est le roi de la punchline et
juste il tient tête
et Mitterrand ça bah évidemment ça ne
passe pas quoi
[Musique]
c'est le président bienvenue au Burkina
Faso
la révolution de Thomas Sankara génère
tellement les intérêts de la France elle
avait toute la perdre
en perdant le Burkina l'occasion pour le
capitaine Sankara de montrer à François
Mitterrand les premiers succès de sa
fougue révolutionnaire le tout ponctué
d'une touche de sympathie le papa blanc
devenant ici dans la bouche des enfants
[Applaudissements]
alors que bon
aucune croyance
auquel livre 5000 au Coran ni la Bible
n'ont jamais pu réconcilier le riche et
le pauvre l'exploitateur et l'exploiter
quand tu regardes le passage
ou Sankara et il dit un petit peu ses
vérité tu vois
que comme cela a été le cas déjà
que des autorités françaises
viennent s'accoquiner avec des autorités
burkinabè africaine
c'est effectivement le capitalisme qui
en profite
et nous sommes prêts pour qu'ensemble
nous lutions contre eux moi ce qui me
choque vraiment c'est toutes
l'hypocrisie qui a quand deux chefs
d'État se rencontrent et là on a un gars
comme Sankara
qui va droit au but alors qu'il est en
face de lui quand même c'est Mitterrand
c'est quand même c'est le chef en fait
il a cité tous les terrains politiques
sur lesquels lui divergent avec la
comportement de la France il y a les
avec le temps qu'on a connu ou cette
formule est sortie où il reprochait à la
France de soutenir le régime
d'apporter dans l'Afrique du Sud
Monsieur François Mitterrand nous
n'avons pas compris comment des bandits
des tueurs
comme Peter Botta ont eu le droit de
parcourir la France si belle
et si propre ils l'ont taché
ils l'ont attaché de leur main et de
leurs pieds couvert de sang moins qui
était à côté
on a senti
l'affaissement des épaules du président
Mitterrand mon père nous raconter ça en
étant mort de rire parce que c'est la
première fois où ils voient un Africain
parler au colon de cette manière là en
s'affirmant et en lui disant mais en
fait moi je vais pas suivre au départ
c'est une agression
politique et l'autre la répliquer
comme il pouvait aussi sans papiers je
pouvais pas moi écouter le président et
puis faire un petit compliment aimable
puis rentrer me coucher et dormir et
c'est c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un
homme c'est un homme un peu dérangeant
un président Sankara
et non c'est vrai il vous titille il
voit il pose des questions quoi avec lui
il n'est pas facile de dormir en paix
il vous laisse pas la conscience
tranquille bon alors moi là-dessus je
suis je suis comme lui hein il faut
qu'il sache que je suis comme lui et dit
ce qu'il pense je le dis aussi et je
trouve que dans certains nombre de ces
jugements il va plus loin qu'il faut à
mon avis qui me permettent de lui parler
du haut de mon expérience
pour la France Afrique c'est pas le
modèle que il fallait la France veut
préserver à tout prix ses intérêts elle
se conduit exactement comme si c'était
encore une colonie on a quelqu'un en
fait qui qui dit non il dit ça cette
époque là pour moi en tout cas pour ma
part pour mon pays c'est terminé
et pendant tout ce temps là son image je
faisais que grandir au Congo au Ghana au
Sénégal en Côte d'Ivoire
un peu partout au Nigeria aux États-Unis
partout à Harlem
[Musique]
je parle au nom de cette vision d'être
qui sont dans les ghettos
[Musique]
noir
sont de culture différente et qui
bénéficient des statuts à peine
supérieur à celui d'un animal
[Musique]
que personne l'empêchait il pouvait
l'empêcher d'aller voir les communautés
noires à Harlem et il y a les
mots
[Applaudissements]
de protection américaine n'ont jamais eu
autant de difficultés à protéger chef de
travail que avec Sankara notre maison
on a dit votre Maison Blanche vous
l'avez faite là où il y a le plus de
noirs
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'image qui veut donner de
lui-même il va à la rencontre du peuple
noir américain et il veut donner cette
image au monde entier que ce sont ses
frères ils sont exploités par les
Américains ce sont des victimes et donc
il va aller voir et il leur fait un
discours
on va dire anti impérialiste on n'est
plus dans une lutte où on pense que au
peuple Burkina B en fait là ça dépasse
les frontières et ça touche à la plus
grande puissance mondiale je vais vous
montrer que je suis prêt contre
l'impérialisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sortir son flingue en disant ça c'est
pour tuer l'impérialisme c'est une
provocation inutile mais ça fait partie
du personnage et de ce qu'il veut
montrer de lui-même
[Applaudissements]
une fois que son message il a dépassé
les frontières ça peut gangriner le
monde entier en fait tous les opprimés
toutes les minorités tous ceux qui sont
oppressés par un système ils peuvent
prendre exemple sur un homme qui a voulu
se lever
les pays du tiers-monde ont interpellé
les pays riches une nouvelle fois en
dénonçant l'impasse ou par éconduire
selon eux la stratégie de règlement de
leur dette il n'est pas possible un
grand nombre de pays en développement de
pays ce qu'ils doivent
[Musique]
la dette ne saurait être payée qui ici
ne souhaite pas que la dette soit
primaire simplement effacer
celui qui ne souhaite pas il peut sortir
prendre son avion et aller tout de suite
là-bas mondiale payer
j'étais là dans la salle à 10h20 je
voyais dans le regard de cette chef
d'État toute l'admination ça a été
terrible nous ne sommes pas responsables
de la dette
vous pouvez l'Europe et finalement on
permis au monde de se débarrasser du
nazisme la dette de sang
c'est l'Occident qui lui doit
nous devons rien à personne il n'y a pas
un morceau de terre dans le monde ou un
[__] n'a pas sué n'est pas mort pour
que les autres vivent bien il y en a pas
qu'on ne verrez pas me dire aujourd'hui
que je dois quelque chose à quelqu'un
c'est nous qui avons servi les autres
aujourd'hui
où on s'assoit ensemble la table ou
c'est nous qui faisons servir ça suffit
il a compris le rapport de force
mondiale et c'est dit je crache mon
venin
advienne que pourra je voudrais que
notre conférence adopte la nécessité de
dire clairement que nous ne pouvons pas
payer la dette non pas dans un esprit
pour éviter que nous n'allions
individuellement nous faire assassiner
et bien le bonjour Depuis Ouaga et je
vous dis on va arrêter de vous regarder
nous maintenant la voix est tracée on y
va là il devenait beaucoup trop billes
c'est-à-dire que d'un coup d'un seul tu
es en train de dire à tous les autres
pays vous pouvez continuer de traiter
avec tous ces gens mais vous pouvez
aussi dire non et si on est 10 à dire
non là forcément c'est sûr que la dette
on va pas la payer
la tête je ne serai pas là la prochaine
conférence
par contre avec le soutien de tous
quand j'ai besoin
avec le soutien de tous vous pourrez
éviter de payer
si la dette c'était la goutte d'eau
j'ai le sentiment
et la peut-être signé son arrêt de moi à
partir de ce discours
à l'intérieur bah forcément il suffit de
la jalousie parce qu'en fait il prend de
l'ampleur
c'est c'est un personnage vraiment
à la fois charismatique et qui du coup
efface tous les gens qui sont autour de
lui
que là en numéro 2 et qui est toujours
là pour écouter et qui finalement
n'arrive pas à voir cet aura que le
frère aîné a mais c'est sûr que ça
suscite déjà l'usine
on a souvent jaloux de son frère il
blesse avec Sankara vivant il pourrait
jamais régner
[Musique]
ou même de me priver
non
[Musique]
donc s'il fait pas il faut là être
vraiment
[Musique]
pour lui dire fais attention il y a
Blaise qui est en train de compoter
contre toi et là Thomas Sankara il a dit
moi c'est mon ami je le tuerai jamais je
fais partie de ceux qui poussaient au
crime je suis à Paris dans son bureau en
furie
énervé que j'étais j'ai dit mais
qu'est-ce que tu fais
on t'a connu bâtard comment se fait-il
que tu laisses Blaise faire ce qu'il est
en train de faire
et la réponse elle m'a été je me bats
mais je me salirai jamais les mains
jamais
[Musique]
chaque fois que je reviens sur ces lieux
là c'est comme si c'était hier
[Musique]
un commando
démarre de la maison de Blaise Compaoré
et ce sont des hommes qui font partie de
sa garde rapprochée
[Musique]
ils sont douze ils sont armés de
kalachnikov
il rentre au Conseil de l'Entente ou
Sankara a prévu une réunion avec
plusieurs de ses collaborateurs ils
arrivent
il tire sur tout ce qui bouge et en
particulier sur la garde rapprochée de
Thomas Sankara il rentre dans le
pavillon
le président est assis par là
et nous autres États assis comme ça moi
aussi
le président est ici qui c'est ici c'est
tirer son survêtement vers le bas
et il est sorti le premier les mains
sans arme
[Musique]
tu fais exécuter comme ça froidement il
se fait buter quoi
elle a été le premier sorti il a été
abattu à bout portant ici
et puis bon ceux qui ont suivi certains
sont tombés par là d'autres par là
moi je me suis couché ici juste là
nous sommes dans l'un des quartiers les
plus misérables de la capitale
son cadavre et ce de ces gardes je t'ai
ici sans cercueil ni pierre tombale
juste quelques mots griffonnés Sankara
tu as été trahie par ton meilleur ami
il y a un détail aussi là
qui m'énerve aussi parce que Blaise
Compaoré il dit quoi il dit que Thomas
Sankara il a été tué par accident il
déclare ça il déclare carrément qu'il a
été tué par accident
on sait que c'est une
exécutions
l'exécute pas accident
je dis que j'étais pas j'étais chez moi
j'étais même malade et lorsque ça tirait
des camarades qui étaient avec mon peu
le confirmer je pense même que c'était
ma maison qu'on attaque et je suis sorti
même dans la rue avec mon arme
pour me défendre donc vous avez des
regrets
aussi
quand même moment de sa vie il est pensé
à nous liquider
dommage
dommage c'est l'impression d'avoir un
oncle qui ment tu sais mais que tu
connais ton oncle donc tu sais qu'il
ment
c'est fou en fait
[Musique]
c'était le ou non il y a pas meilleur
aveu que de dire c'était lui ou non et
aujourd'hui on veut lui dire non il faut
passer l'éponge tout ça c'est derrière
c'est pas grave on peut s'entendre non
quelques jours avant Thomas Sankara est
Blaise Compaoré ils étaient en train de
danser ensemble
quelques jours avant son exécution c'est
à dire que le gars savait déjà qu'il
allait l'exécuter et il faisait comme si
rien n'allait se passer
ça c'est ouf ça montre à quel point
quand même l'être humain il est capable
de d'user de duplicité comme ça pour
arriver à ses fins
tant que convaincu que ces places
comparés qui l'assassiné est-ce que toi
dans ton nature tu es convaincu ben en
tout cas c'est sous ses ordres forcément
de façon à qui profite le crime quand tu
regardes c'est lui qui prend le pouvoir
[Musique]
l'histoire elle est marrante quoi c'est
à dire que quand on décide de sortir
Compaoré les premières qui sortent et
les femmes avec leur spatule et qui
disent tu dégages
[Musique]
et c'est les femmes qui le font
[Applaudissements]
les femmes en qui sont capables placer à
la fois toute sa confiance et c'était
dit il faut absolument miser sur elle si
on veut mener la révolution en fait
elles ont juste bouclé la boucle et
elles ont dit aussi que tu sors et après
effectivement toute la jeunesse a repris
et c'est comme ça que comparé était
sorti
en 2014 va se lever une insurrection
populaire massive
[Musique]
où les gens ont renversé un gouvernement
en affrontant les militaires en levant
les mains au ciel
de manifester pacifiquement montrer à la
fin du monde entier que
les
frères
j'ai grandi dans ce pays vivre à genoux
toute sa vie c'est pas possible c'est
pas une vie on se considère
effectivement comme les enfants de 140
et avec son portrait que les jeunes
défilé dans le rideau
[Musique]
donc il a été réhabilité comme ça sur
toi
pour le peuple
merci camarade
je pense aussi à mes enfants à mes
petits-enfants qui doivent hériter quand
même de quelque chose quoi
toute la vie faut quand même qu'on leur
ait quelque chose
ne serait-ce qu'un morceau de résistance
pour qu'il puisse continuer
sinon on dit si tu te couches tu meurs
[Musique]
le pousse aujourd'hui il est encore plus
aimé plus connu plus populaire que sur
la révolution
[Musique]
à ceux qui ont assassiné Thomas Sankara
qu'ils ont échoué de toute évidence et
voilà que 33 ans après on a quand même
une génération qui épouse les idées de
Thomas Sankara comme si elle avait connu
directement et je trouve que ça c'est un
triomphe c'est une victoire j'aime bien
cette phrase si vous tuez Thomas Sankara
des milliers de Thomas Sankara avant
d'être punchline
[Musique]
ça met des bâtons dans les roues donc ça
parle à bateau rompu dis-leur que les
jeunesses de Sankara ne seront plus
voilà un chef d'État comme les Africains
n'auront plus à cause de traite comme
Blaise Compaoré le corrompu
l'évolutionnaire comme Che Guevara on
prend par les capables de mettre des
mecs comme Mitterrand dans la baraque et
il y a de la haine ici comme dans
beaucoup d'endroits parce qu'au pays des
droits de l'homme j'ai pas vu beaucoup
d'endroits un traité d'air à chaque
billet donc on voit la frix-piller bien
sûr sur la place du cœur certains ont de
la glace pilée le peuple meurt de faim
pendant que l'argent est gaspiller donc
c'est la Patrie ou la mort Thomas
Sankara
Thomas
on est ensemble la suite
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce documentaire
sur la ville de Thomas Sankara j'espère
que ça vous a plu un grand merci à Yohan
Malka et toutes les équipes de brutes
qui ont réalisé ce documentaire au
Burkina Faso en 2021 avec un contexte
politique qui n'était pas du tout simple
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner aux
chaînes Youtube de brut pour ne rien
rater de nos prochaines vidéos et
documentaires et je vous dis à très
bientôt